(phone ringing)
(typing)
(drizzling on roof)
(ominous music)
- [Newscaster] Sunny,
with highs at about 76,
you can take a look at the...
Excuse me...
Are you sure?
This just in, we might have rain.
(gasps)
Are you sure?
Julia, I can't be wrong.
Los Angeles will be experiencing
a quarter inch of rain.
(gasps)
- That's so much.
- It's happening.
- So whip out your umbrellas, folks.
This could be a rain of terror.
(suspenseful music)
- We gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go!
- The dispensaries are going to close!
- Guys, I've seen this before,
just stay inside and we'll be okay.
- I don't know how to use this thing!
- Make it open.
- Is there an on button?
- Open it!
- It's okay, Mr. Woofington, it's okay.
- Drive much slower,
and sometimes pull over
if it gets too scary.
(screams)
(gagging)
(crying)
(heavy breathing)
- Guys, wait... the sun is coming out!
(playful music)
(laughter)
- Wow, that was a crazy 11 seconds.
(phones ringing)
(shaking)
- Did you just feel that?
- I think we just had an earthquake.
- Oh.
(laughter)
- Does this mean the drought is over?